comment est ce que vous avez vous
analysé en fait sept mouvements nuit de
bouc qui s depuis le 31 mars sur la
place de la république est ce que pour
vous c'est un feu de paille ou ça veut
dire quelque chose je pense que on a
observé ce type de mouvement depuis la
révolution française à intervalles
réguliers avec des organisations
culturelles qui dépendent du moment
difficile de savoir si ça va durer
déboucher sur une structuration etc
c'est une des formes de la démocratie
voilà la démocratie elle est vivante
elle a beaucoup de formes différentes
elle finit en général dans les régimes
démocratiques par s'organiser dans une
démocratie qui représente ça vous choque
pas qu'on occupe des places comme ça
tous les soirs
parce qu'ils ne choque pas c'est à
démocratie peut s'exprimer de toutes les
façons la condition qu'elle ne troublait
pas la paix civile
vous êtes d'accord guillaume balas là
c'est une forme d'engagement
démocratique classique que ce qui
affleure partout et pas simplement en
france pour le meilleur jeu mais
évidemment lui debout là dedans mais
pour le pire ce qu'on a vu en autriche
avec le vote c'est la recherche de la
source et le vote de lectra les armes
est donc exactement je pense que partout
il ya la recherche de la souveraineté
c'est-à-dire comment aujourd'hui des
peuples peuvent reprendre leur destin en
mains face notamment ce qui paraît une
dilution du pouvoir politique une
incapacité du politique et des
représentants à agir a expliqué et donc
par tous à la dilution est pas de
verticalité pour vous je pense que la
dilution elle se fait dans une nouvelle
verticalité c'est à dire que les gaffes
à google les compagnies les grandes
multinationales traditionnel détiennent
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de pouvoir
économique technologique et donc de
pouvoir politique y compris ils mettent
à la gendarme fait du monde entier un
certain nombre de nouvelles stratégies
de nouveaux produits a lancé et de
nouveaux contrôles de ce que sont nos
vies et donc je pense qu on est dans une
volonté de contrôle démocratique a
retrouvé exactement je pense que sa
commandite nuit debout comme d'autres
choses sont le signe de sa et donc il
faut que nous les représentants et bien
nous trouvons des solutions nouvelles si
nous voulons pas que ça explose je vois
vraiment comment vous le percevez
comment vous l'analysez
hayder guardian à bâle depuis l'espagne
vous qui avez connu en fait ces
mouvements en fait d' indignés pendant
quelques mois notamment à madrid à la
costa del sol oui c'est vrai que ce qui
était en train d'arriver en france ce
qui s'est passé il ya quelques uns en
espagne je pense qu'il faut voir une
toujours le côté positif
enfin il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui se
sentent dit il faut qu'on reprenne la
démocratie qu'il faut qu'on participe en
politique
et ça c'est très bien parce que dans les
derniers temps en espagne mais je pense
qu'un peu partout les gens ils avaient
regardé la politique d'un autre côté il
ne s'impliquaient plus il ne
s'impliquaient plus du tout et nous
aussi du côté de la politique on se
sentait un peu seul il faut qu'on prenne
des décisions mais on veut avoir les
gens avec nous on veut discuter avec les
gens vont pouvoir prendre des décisions
en commun mais je veux retourner une
chose que déjà guillaume je trouve que
c'est très important ce n'est pas
seulement qu'il ya une verticalité de la
politique ce n'est pas que les gens se
sont vus dépourvu c'est que même la
politique à un moment donné elle s'est
vu impuissante à agir et c'est ça ce que
les gens ils ont regardé et 70 il faut
qu'on prenne encore le pouvoir et il
faut qu'on puisse changer les choses et
là je pense qu'il faut qu'on tire deux
leçons ses dents du côté de la politique
mais quand on voit dominique riquet par
exemple à quel point la situation paraît
bloquée en france on voit les
raffineries bloquées les centrales
nucléaires qui se sont engagés également
en fait dans le mouvement là sncf la
ratp qui appellent à une grève illimitée
à partir du 2 juin
il ya une volonté en fait de débat
public il ya une volonté typique en fait
de mettre sur la table ces questions
sociales sociétales de lois du travail
etc
où est le blocage selon vous au niveau
social en france à ce que c'est de la
part des syndicats ce que c'est de la
part du gouvernement
ou est-ce que ça bloque on observe
quelque chose qui est plus inhabituel
est moins fréquent qui est un blocage
gauche gauche six puis dix ans et il est
dans ce qu'on a pu connaître ça
effectivement 2011 sur la loi contre les
retraites de françois fillon voilà donc
il sort de lait pur classique mais il
est d'autant plus rude
il est d'autant plus rude que il
s'exerce si je puis dire dans la même
direction
là c'est compliqué il ya beaucoup de
choses à la fois de contestation
de la loi dans le fond la démocratie
représentative elle fonctionne comme ça
avec des corps intermédiaires
donc c'est pas une logique il ya aussi
probablement un peu plus que ça il ya un
problème peut-être un peu plus
personnalisé un peu plus humanisé si je
puis dire sur la personnalité manuel
valls et peut-être aussi du secrétaire
général de rsf
donc et puis il y à aussi là un choc
j'irai culturelle sur les bêtes inde
entre guillemets avec d'un côté les
usages du 49-3 banquier a dû sage dégâts
alain je conteste pas ça et de l'autre
côté les usages de la grève bon il ya un
conflit là que l'état conflit à la fois
je pense idiot le gicb est à mon avis un
conflit de pouvoir